when the working week is done Eddie you
know what it's time for GS news top five
oh really I was just going to say that
oh I will be that with us
Call of Duty World War two officially
announced this week oh boy
are you ready - all ready with lock and
load sledgehammer games officially
announced call it at your World War two
this week coming out November for
PlayStation for PC and Xbox one sounds
like a band of brothers type game you
play a low-level kind of like a grunt I
believe there's some connection to
transformers uh yeah just Moe is gonna
be playing your sergeant I can't
remember his name but I know that he's a
34 year old from Oklahoma why remember
that specific fact I don't know but it
looks quite cinematic like a return to
the Hall the duties of the past it does
and I think that might be exactly what
it needs after infinite warfare I mean
good game but didn't resonate with the
audience so another great thing about
Call of Duty obviously is multiplayer
yep and they're talking about you know
this new mode called war mode and it
sounds like operations from battlefield
one potentially and then the other big
thing is headquarters which is similar
to it sounds like destinies the tower
kind of like those social spaces where
you can you know get together with
friends and you know sync up and you
know see your stats and customize your
character and everything from there so
seems like they're making a lot of cool
steps we're gonna learn more about
multiplayer coming at you three-engine
so very soon hey Edie
hello what did you say to me when I said
do you want to do top 5 today is there
gonna be an overwatch story cuz this so
I'm in and watch is getting a bunch of
cool skins fit diva she's getting up
assigned police again but the only way
you can get it is by playing heroes of
the storm if you play heroes of the
storm with a friend and you play up to
five games at each week for the next
three weeks you can unlock a bunch of
cool stuff so first week you can get
access to any Ginji who was part of a
similar promotion a while ago you
haven't have another shot at him and
you'll also get some of his skins and
sort of banners and sprays for heroes of
the storm as well because he's in that
in week two you'll have a chance to get
the diva skin with pulling five games
third week you get sprays for divas hot
stuff and fourth week you get ten loot
boxes for both overwatch and heroes
storm they're playing five games with
your fans that's a lot of loot boxes
that's like 20 boxes Valley easy all
four playing their MOBA game which is
you know not bad I played a lot of it I
quite enjoyed it it's a fun dirty mobile
a pretty good if you're gonna play them
oh yeah easy one to get it yeah it only
takes like 20 minutes of your life if
you like overwatch can get all this cool
[ __ ] just by playing cater to the storm
and it's free to play if your PC
although Jeff Kaplan has said the
console players the diva and ginyu skin
will be coming to loot boxes eventually
I've never seen Dorothy explore I have
seen Dora the explora
speaking of Dora the explora sniper
ghost Warrior 3 I'm not going to make
the jokes it's easy to make their sniper
no it's maybe needed a god damnit even
snuffed me for it so the guys Floria 3
came out this week and it was found to
have over five-minute loading times on
ps4 which is caused quite a ruckus in
online communities now to prove to you
how long it is I'm going to put up
b-roll on the loading screen from sniper
ghost Warrior 3 and try to get through
this whole story before the game loads
the developer came out and said that the
loading screens were so long at the
start as a trade-off because once you're
actually in the game it does load quite
fast when you fast travel when you get
killed all that kind of stuff
what is pretty quick once you get in
there but we're still talking a longer
load than the initial 4 GPA yes
something like that it is it is a long
time I had enough time to go make a cup
of tea to come back and it was still
loading as well with sniper ghost
Warrior 3 on release that people found
there was no multiplayer that was
promised the developer has said that
they didn't put the multiplayer in
because I wanted to focus on the
single-player experience but they're
going to be bringing it out for free in
quarter 3 2017 so that's at least six
months away but they are going to be
rolling out updates apparently to keep
to keep people interested in playing
still hasn't loaded so you can go watch
Dora the Explorer yeah three games
everybody likes free games do you like
bring him to the best they'll cost them
to and the investment is so low that you
can pretty much enjoy anything which you
definitely will this month on
PlayStation if you've got PlayStation
Plus because they have some really good
operating keep yourself on ps3 you can
grab blood knights and put rail three
pirates and merchants then on video you
can grab laser disco defenders and type
Rider
you can also get those games through
cross by on ps4 but it's the other ps4
offering so I think I really worth
getting excited about dating food my
very favourite telltale games tells me
more Ricky I played the first episode
and didn't keep going but I need to get
bits in my back I'll get there okay
it's great it's super funny it's
exceptional they've also got abs ooh for
a complete change of pace if you just
want like serenity and fun it sounds
like PlayStation have you so sorted out
this month if you're in Europe you will
get alienation if you if you prefer
mowing through hordes of aliens - mowing
through the ocean with a great workshop
and you can enjoy that as it has come
with all his persona gear so we can talk
about the things but it's the wrong
persona yet talk about the Santa fire
but you're really far too certified now
on - I'm 120 hours into percent of 5 I'm
so you're actually so far in if you were
to stream where you're up to right now
yeah you would get in a lot of trouble
with Atlas yeah this is like really
unique they seem to be very tight-lipped
if I don't want anyone to reveal
anything about the studies also caserta
which is really weak because it was it
was out in Japan September a lot here a
long time ago but basically they're
their original ask was bullet when I
wasn't really on it was a very angry off
to just remiss in place not to show any
of the game past
in game day of July 7 again which is not
very far alright also like perspective
the game starts in April so it's not
very much at all and players like what
the hell like we want to see it like we
want to see the game you know these are
your fans who are playing it wanting to
watch like what the games like and
everything uh and atlas got pretty
cranked yeah having the head that they
were threatened they would threaten ah
anyone who violated there were streaming
restrictions with potentially like an
account suspension yeah like twitch
takedown yeah twitch takedowns which
upset everybody so now they pushed it
back and you can stream up to November
in gaming remember yeah a bit more time
it's a bit more time bit still like
Alice should know what the gaming sort
of landscape is like now yeah we'll just
do that every people don't wanna see
spoilers they won't watch them it's
weird because surely like those Let's
Plays and live streams I feel like
that's exactly designed for people who
perhaps aren't like into maybe that
style a game with it exactly what's
going to pick it up they just want to
watch it through exactly like when John
Baum did that in a fall let's play I got
a whole bunch of readers into it because
there's never seen anything so crazy
yeah but it had the chance to see what
it was like yeah so it's kind of a shame
that atlas have said you know they've
said sorry if people found the threat
threatening
but ah they've moved it back and when
they feel like they have a perched like
a reasonable compromise sir I mean you
shouldn't see spoilers I mean you could
definitely look up spoilers if you
wanted to what
that's where has happened obviously if
you want to know more about called duty
what with two persona 5 all the video
games stuff you can find a lot of
content on GameSpot about those games in
particular and more this week a bit I
took the news this week anything they
say Jess next week no just that I'll see
them they have a good weekend yeah okay
yeah okay so yeah okay 1/4 million say
to the angry chameleon what do you say
you need to be a comic chameleon oh that
wasn't funny though